could you talk about how you came upon
this property and and transformed it
into these larger features and and what
that process was it began in the late
1950s in Belgium created by payoh and
pale started with one book they came out
of a story with this character Johan and
they were little teeny characters within
that story and then they got the most
right ends to pay oh and then payoh
created his first introduction in Smurf
Village with that and then many books
after that followed one of which was
called the Smurfette or the strim fat
and that's what this movie was based on
the second movie on Smurfette story in
that those books were hugely successful
in Romance language countries
predominantly so throughout Europe and
Latin America they were extremely
successful in nineteen late nineteen
seventy-nine early nineteen eighty was a
an executive at ABC a little young
executive at ABC and another young
friend of mine named brandon tartikoff
was the very young president of NBC at
that point and we were in Hawaii
together and he said no one at my
network loves eight o'clock or saturday
morning programming you love it I want
you to read three books for me and tell
me whether you think they should be at
eight o'clock or whether they should be
saturday morning and when the when the
president of the opposing network asks
you to as a friend to read something you
read it that night and you get back to
him in the morning which even on
vacation I did and we had an interesting
conversation that followed which was do
you see it written exactly as peyo was
written it or can you add more
subversive adult humor so it operates on
two levels and he said I really love
them the way they are and I want to do
then I said then he really belong on
Saturday morning not not at eight
o'clock and about a year later he sent
me a note and said in about a month tune
in and it was hanna-barbera's cartoon
starting in nineteen eighty one that I
think to this day is
including cartoons like spongebob and
others is still the largest most viewed
cartoon in history the truth no matter
is Raj and I would always ask each other
what would pay Oh think okay so we tried
to for the fans of the books the fans of
the animation we worked very hard to
stay true to his writing in that and
sometimes a dialogue will come directly
out of an episode sometimes we I would
be I was always on the phone at least
once a week with his daughter once in a
while with his son the daughter runs the
business the Sun is a theory and
veronique theory what it draws the comic
books and we they would read every set
of new pages and we would talk about
them we'd shaped them with them with the
writers so there was a constant
involvement from Belgium with what are
what our movie finally ended up to be
and we worked very very hard with
everyone in Paris and the Film
Commission everywhere else to get these
done properly but we got a Steadicam
approved by the church and by the
government that the government controls
the facade of Notre Dame and the church
controls the sanctuary we were never in
the sanctuary we're only on the facade
but both approved because the Smurfs are
loved in France so we were able to do
something no one else had ever done
which is to take a Steadicam my French
Steadicam operator and run him through
and we were all up on that roof run him
through the the flying buttresses the
same thing was true with the Palais
Garnier which is you know the Opera
House and no one had ever been able to
shoot on its stage talking to everyone
in the audience and they had some second
unit work that they did for Sherlock
Holmes the second Sherlock Holmes but no
one's ever and phantom of the opera had
a little bit of second unit work plates
and things but we shot there three days
fold actually two nights and a day and
we were able to shoot all the audience
reactions and Gargamel on stage and
everything shooting this way was
actually shot in Montreal everything
shooting that way was shot in Paris the
family arena has always been sort of a
stepchild it's never been
it's always been seen as something well
they make that for kids but I think
certainly over the last 10 years and
Jeffrey Katzenberg was a huge leader in
this with his films at Disney and later
with Shrek and others these films now
operate on two levels one entire level
for adults one entire level for younger
people in that our first movie the first
Smurfs one third of the audience was
children one-third okay one-third were
their parents and one-third were those
who grew up on the Smurfs watching the
cartoon or an internationally reading
the books and so it was a nostalgia
factor as well and we realize that the
movie that we had made then was a movie
the cater to that that cater to those
two levels so I think there's been a
groundswell the the accolades other than
there are the Critics Awards and all
those actually have family categories
hopefully someday the Academy will and
and and the Foreign Press Association
will but around the world these are the
films that stay on on shelves in video
stores longer than any other titles but
more importantly they stay on the
shelves of families and their seen over
and over and over and over again and I
had a really interesting experience a
year ago I moved back to Los Angeles
from North Carolina where I was the Dean
of the film school at University of
North Carolina and all of my students
there these are students of course a lot
of face hair and there's they are
wearing black not that I'm wearing I'm
wearing a lot of black too i guess but
they're all wearing black and they were
all too cool for the room but one by one
275 of them made their way up to my
office to say my whole love of film my
sense of values is a human being we're
all based on the mighty ducks you know
and I would hear stories about the
mighty ducks movies from them and in a
funny way that confirmed for me that the
life that I chose to seek out these
movies in addition to dramas adult
dramas but to seek out these family
movies and to put into them stories of
blended families
issues at teenagers face to put those in
that that those little seeds that get
planted in a movie of someone who's six
seven eight ten twelve will later ten
years later 15-20 years later pay off in
the kind of citizen citizen and the kind
of filmmakers that we have and so for me
it was it was a hugely unexpected
benefit by being a Dean